hey this is the special rapporteur here
for geek culture we are at the Capcom
boot where they have showing off the
latest build of Marvel vs. Capcom
infinite as you can see there is a
life-size statue of Ultron with the
crystal gem so that is the most boss
thing ever you can actually go on and
get as close to the throne as possible
it's got a lot of a comic book fans just
coming here to pay homage to the God
himself of course you got the playable
builds over there and the kiosks long
lines here just to get your hands on MVP
I a lot of people I've been playing it
and of course at the very same time they
drop the super good news that the beta
would be going live so if you aren't
able to get into e3 you can still play
Marvel in the comfort of your home
really cool marketing
that no one really was expecting to see
here take 25 minutes just to get in line
and get your hands on marble
then you've got the giant monster hunter
which I guess is their
headliner monster hunter world a very
immersive
celebration of Monster Hunter with his
crazy dragon croc they have pulled out
all the stops at their booth
I'm sorry dude and the rainforest
another nice moral birthday infinite
poster there
and of course when it comes to cat palm
we're talking about that super sick
merchandise and let's see what they have
this year behind those glass cases
hey those are the ones that you see as
we all Capcom Pro Tour asia ones they're
all spamming it those crazy camera guy
and skin i really like this one it here
the street fighter v Panthera fights mix
this is a throwback to that old Jupiter
2 alpha art I believe with Sakura in the
background and it was evil Ryu and it
was a kuma but this time they got Korean
in the background
what we easy for fresh stock right here
3/4 X these old shoes you see this I
make a gene wait I would rock this and
they've got awesome stock my stand
amazing stuff
what are these dragon balls no they are
infinite so
big a bison over there hey Connecticut's
our home boys all the way out from
Singapore with that full science figure
of evil view really dope stuff
screaming is a blow up this is where all
the pro players are showing on the
latest build of the game
and it looks like they're doing some
tournaments here
we got call me yo we got data on
commentary
I've never heard him it looks like three
four to five tournament and you've got
the latest build often tree party to the
final challengers Island ten even reuse
super broken probably attack should we
join this we should jump into this right
now
your commentaries not to make more songs
so cheaper i
saving the whole where i dairy store
specialist he's doing like commentary
hardest-working you
have it's true and epoxy got the your
show to resign it three crimes if you
still have a time tomorrow to get your
time I got the Moses in the back spear
horse
ah
yes and we come here to the 30th
anniversary obviously butter and all
started with this game right here I was
a bit too young to actually get my hands
on it but this is the actual poster
look at that artwork look at it what is
this and they had Mount Rushmore for
some reason I let me get it really looks
kind of funky
moving on to the game that really puts
three predator in the map I did not know
that Blanca likes to eat
would
know all your history that we're in a
museum right now
iconic very effeminate androgynous Ken
and Ryu for the Alpha series
thirty years
the answer lies in the heart of battle
ah
yes the one that was very difficult to
play third strike all that pairing not
really a commercial success but still
played very today at a cooperation cup
and many regarded as the most
technically difficult games ever play
this is where we got our start here are
three point four where I met cameraman
where I met skins so this is a very dear
game to be Street Fighter 4 in all its
iterations reach the Roofus I still miss
this game very dearly and the one that
we're currently playing that took us
into the generation of eSports Street
Fighter 5
really brought us from a niche culture
to the mainstream now we're playing for
like a quarter of a million dollars I
hope they can get at some of
pause on that but this is what's going
to take us to the future this is what
brought us on to you know like cable TV
three four to five and who knows what
the future holds but at least we know
for next year that is going to be Marvel
vs. Capcom and I'm looking forward to
our new Disney and Marvel overlords so
yeah this is the Capcom booth come check
it out